a former ukrainian mp with his own tv
channel but is yevon marieff also being
considered by russia as a possible
candidate to lead a puppet government in
ukraine that's what britain's foreign
office has claimed he's dismissed the
allegation as nonsense
his facebook page openly mocking it
he also wrote the time of pro-western
and pro-russian politicians in ukraine
is long gone the ukrainian people need
the rule of law peace and new political
leaders
but the british claims of a russian plot
to install a pro-kremlin regime ran true
in kiev even if the name of its
potential leader didn't
is one of that people they would love to
see
in the new government but at the same
time i
i have
serious doubts that
he is the leader
of that you know
group
because he's not significant enough
it shows how russia's military buildup
around ukraine isn't the only worry for
western allies that suspect a hidden
hand as well
in a rare release of classified
information the uk also alleged other
former ukrainian politicians are in
contact with russian spies apparently
involved in planning for an attack on
ukraine
sky news understands the claim was based
on a uk intelligence analysis that drew
on u.s led intelligence it's a very
unusual thing for the foreign officers
to do and no doubt it's based on
intelligence gathering
at the highest level
but i think it's a useful
thing to do because what it demonstrates
to russia very clearly
is that we know their intent we are in
no doubt at all as to what they're
trying to achieve
the kremlin strongly denied the
allegations accusing the uk of peddling
fake news but this crisis is real and
the stakes are high
ukraine's ambassador to the uk spelling
out what it might mean if attempts by
western allies to defuse tensions with
russia fail we have nowhere to to go i
mean we corner it in our own biggest
land in europe we will fight sudanese
unfortunately so many people of our
nation will probably die but we will try
to get to that world as many russians as
they come
new shipments of u.s weapons to bolster
ukraine's defenses against any new
russian attack even though neither side
has yet given up on a diplomatic route
out of this standoff
debra haynes sky news